the cbi's very own Mr growth our
director General Tony danker
a leading voice for British business
good morning everybody now attracting
attention for all the wrong reasons
after two years at the helm of one of
Britain's biggest business groups Tony
danker has been dismissed following an
allegation of sexual harassment
that along with a number of other
allegations against CBI staff have
plunged the organization into crisis the
CBI board said in a statement the
allegations that have been made over
recent weeks about the CBI have been
devastating while investigations
continue into a number of these it is
already clear to all of us that they
have been serious failings in how we
have acted as an organization we must do
better and we must be better
but the decision has left danker feeling
aggrieved I was appalled to learn about
the revelations for the first time last
week I was nevertheless shocked to learn
this morning that I have been dismissed
from the CBI instead of being invited to
put my position forward as was
originally confirmed dankers is by far
the most high profile departure but
three others have been suspended and the
investigation isn't even complete yet
the CBI has received dozens of
complaints about its staff raising
questions about the workplace culture
the Scandal has rocked the CBI whose
influence some Financial viability rests
on the backing of its 190 000 members
they pay as much as 50 000 pounds a year
to be part of the organization and
they're asking difficult questions if
people don't behave in the right way
toward their colleagues then you won't
reinvent your culture because that's
what this is about that's a a big
challenge but I'm sure that members you
know will will allow the CBI that
opportunity
many will not all but many will his
replacement brain Newton Smith the
organization's former Chief Economist
and widely considered to be a safe Pair
of Hands I hope that she will be capable
of sorting out this culture and putting
back the CBI where we need it to be
which is confidently
um and responsibly representing business
across the UK thanks very much indeed
danker has left the stage but will the
cbi's members also be heading for the
exit 91 Sky News